もうつけたよん
たい
うんそれぞれ大丈夫
[音楽]
こんにちははじめ社長ですね
良い子の口板
皆さんしてますでしょうかこちらですよいこのプチバルーンっていう行為
風船ではないんですよ風船ではないんですよどっちまるって言う中野
なんてないんでもちょっと説明しづらいこういう感じで作り方
パイプに巻きつけます課題時はダメてください柔らかい時をシェアしてください
[音楽]
ダーヌー
今良い子じゃないんですけどそれ世界やってみましょうあえてに巻き付ける
まあこうだコードが懐かしいいよいよ懐かしいこんな感じですこういう形で巻き付けて
コストナースともできるんですよ
のっ
[音楽]
感じなんですけどもうちょっと俺には小さすぎるこれはいえ子じゃないからさ
小さい風船6ためな向けをこんな小さいソロ使わずに
今回はこちらがめちゃくちゃでかいつつにこうやってこのムービー
私6くん本当
おっ
あ好きだよ
うんじゃあねっ
bel
ブーブちゃんと全部隠れるあああっっでそれっわれ
れる頭がこうなるっていうのは万人年間を見せようかもこれで差分ねほんまにしたいと
思いないかね
まーすべくで大きくなるか分からないんですけども実際にやってみようと思います
amane
でちゃんと穴をふさぐとこうなります
ちょっと待ってこれもさんでイレッサいきます
持っ
なんでよしこれなら大丈夫ん
は
なめてんのこれはこれでこれですこれです
ん
絶世ちょっと待ったら電話今じゃないああ
を好きだぞん
[音楽]
で本当にで書いたやつなんでああ
あっていえーいえーい
やでしょ良いグループ aaa
わかるかな憲法で会横でぜひ
みんなの五ツクってみたらいいと思います
いいいいいい
んじゃあ
[音楽]
はーい
いっ
うっ
おすすめくんあゆちゃ
[音楽]
t
ええええええ
ていた
me
ええええええ